hi everybody um I'm going to be sharing
today about documenting things and how
doing this with intention can really
help big organizations do hard things
around Tech and
culture so I'm Julie louns I am a marine
ecologist and I grew up in the r and
open science communities and documenting
things has been a big big um part of my
shift towards uh doing my own research
to supporting other research teams doing
research um and so I do that now through
a program called open Scapes and this is
a huge collaborative effort with many
many people that I'm going to be sharing
from um so let's talk about documenting
things openly for future
us so first of all um things is all of
the things uh this is your code and
Analysis icies your teaching resources
your onboarding and Community
documentation your fieldwork your lab
notebooks events that you've got your
blog posts like you name it and future
us is really a mindset and a habit
around the idea that you're doing this
work for our for yourself for ourselves
for our teams for our communities and
really thinking about that on different
time scales in the next hour in the next
week in the next decade so this is
really getting Beyond theide aidea of
working by yourself on your own laptop
and really thinking about how to be
intentional and inclusive in the in the
work that you do so that others can
benefit as
well um so documenting things does not
have to be painful that's one of the
things I'd like to share today um and in
fact it's supposed to be helpful it's
supposed to be there for you so that
you're not having to repeat the same
mistakes or frustrations that you or
others have had in the past it does
however take time and intention um it
takes um support of yourself and others
and it really means kind of slowing down
briefly in order to speed up for
yourself and others um over the long
term so really the purpose today is to
help you document things effectively and
also hear stories about how
documentation can be can be visible and
valued and help teams be efficient
productive and less lonely so the
structure of this talk is going to be a
five minute lightening talk with
practical tips and this is inspired by
Jenny Bryan naming files and Jenny Brian
has been such a role model and teacher
about how to document things well and
share with others and so I'm trying to
bring some of that here and then we'll
have 10minute stories about repeatable
strategies from Community organizations
at Nasa and other places um so let's
let's get started um documenting things
have a place have an audience in mind
designed for readability and
accessibility have a place it doesn't
matter where at first just write it down
write it down somewhere some kind of
software you're using get it get it on
get it have have a place there then
having that place will let you write as
you go you'll be able to develop a habit
of writing things in that place and one
of the ways you'll do that is by copying
and pasting things you're already
writing take it from that slack message
that email um this will help you break
down documentation that otherwise can
seem like a big looming task that might
take weeks to do um keyboard shortcuts
are great for cutting and pasting uh
text from one place to another you'll be
able to write in a modular way writing
in small bits is less daunting and it's
easier to maintain collaboratively um
you'll be able to write these little
bits in a way that can be networked so
that you can link back and forth to them
because you don't need a a linear flow
when you're writing documentation this
will also help you um follow the concept
of don't repeat yourself which is
something that we can borrow from coding
where you're trying to have your code
only written once that you call by
functions there's often also no true
order to what you're documenting and so
you'll be moving things around as you
develop having an audience in mind is
key here um you're writing this for
someone that someone is probably you and
many others and different audiences at
different entry points so you can make
your documentation engaging it doesn't
have to be dry or
distant writing in an inclusive tone is
part of this and having the mindset of
we're in this together and that your
readers are intelligent people and
they're here and they're here to learn
from you so you can really consider your
goals for your documentation and the
style that you want to have that can
welcome readers you can avoid specific
words that trivialize pretty complex
things like simply clone the repo like
there's a lot to unpack in a statement
like that and thinking about how to how
to meet folks where they are there's a
lot of thoughtful resources that you can
emulate and these are just a few
narrate code in small chunks if you're
presenting code so this is um a you can
you can narrate uh your code in a way
that you would say it out loud if you
were teaching it um and you can match
that tone with your purpose um
especially as you're trying to highlight
specific parts of your code for for
Learners to focus on uh we learned this
morning that quto has a new code
annotation feature to help in this in
this as
well sharing early is a big part about
writing documentation you want to be
able to have this be useful for for
folks as soon as possible and you want
to be able to iterate it and receive
feedback and incorporate that feedback
to improve it um this is where the idea
of open comes in and open does not need
to mean public open can mean shared with
your team um and you're able to leverage
different Technologies and the
permissions that come with them so that
you can share what you want broadly and
also keep things private I think about
this as leaving breadcrumbs for yourself
and in this example this is a public to
documentation for NOA Fisheries where
they're still able to include internal
links that are just accessible to them
but we're all able to benefit from this
documentation lastly design for
readability and accessibility and we're
able to leverage a lot of defaults on
the on the software side and best
practices on the community side in order
to um support these goals um using
section headers is one um one thing we
can do here these are important for
screen readers to help describe the
section and flow of a document and
you're able to Anchor to them directly
so that you're able to share a URL
specifically anchored to a certain
section of your documentation naming
things can be really key here um and
you're able to embrace the idea of the
slug where the name of the header
becomes the URL so that you're able to
give a little bit more information about
what that header is use text formatting
in your documentation this will help you
your readers follow along you're able to
hyperlink to the thing that is important
for people to look at rather than a word
like here or this that is it can be
ambiguous and hard to see as well you're
also able to distinguish code with fonts
um and use markdown um in in this case
as well using alternative text for
images is really important this is um
something that describes the details of
the take-home messages of the visuals so
it's different from a caption in that it
will actually describe that a round
Hedgehog is knitting a yellow sock a
rabbit with a teal beanie is wearing one
yellow one yellow sock and it watches in
anticipation and a shelf to the left of
them contains yarn in a tote labeled
text and knitting patterns in that tote
are labeled
code so that is that concludes the
lightning talk about documenting things
and I wanted now shift to what's
possible about this and tell a few
stories about our work with open
Scapes um so putting a focus on
documentation has enabled NASA to
collaborate across divisions and support
users that are transitioning to Earth
data
Cloud so as a reminder NASA collects an
amazing amount of data about our Earth
they have many satellites and missions
that are collecting data that are freely
available for users who are studying our
planet who are studying climate change
who are studying Public Health
agriculture sea ice melt a lot of
awesome and important work and these
data have been traditionally downloaded
by researchers in order to do analyses
locally and after many years of effort
and planning these data are being
migrated to the cloud in AWS West 2 and
this means that researchers are going to
be taking their compute to the cloud in
order to analyze these data this means
that this is a a big shift in the way
researchers have worked their entire
careers and it's also a shift for the
NASA staff who support researchers in
terms of how they teach users to access
and work with these
data and this teaching this NASA NASA
Earth data cloud is going on by learning
as a community as we go so the NASA open
Scapes project is a uh project that I
lead with my co-lead Aaron Robinson and
we um are supporting a mentor group
across the NASA earth science data
centers and those folks are creating and
teaching common tutorials that um that
researchers are using to migrate their
analytical workflows to the cloud so
this is a huge effort around connecting
folks from different parts of an
organization having them be in a
comfortable environment to learn
together to teach together to write
documentation together um there's a lot
of um emphasis that we put on building a
psychologically safe space to answer to
ask questions to have a growth mindset
where we're able to learn and do
together um what I'm not going to talk
about today is all of the amazing work
that these folks are doing to support
researchers and instead I want to focus
on the documentation that makes it
possible um so first of all we have a
place that researchers can go to to
learn um when to Cloud how to think
about uh using the cloud with r and
Python and other approaches so this is
the earth data Cloud cookbook it's made
with quto it's hosted on a GitHub
reposit
that we're able to contribute to with
Jupiter notebooks and and our markdown
documents and otherwise but so this is
the place that we started to have a
place to contribute
to our audience was really important we
realized that it needed to be us first
and then specific researchers and so
this diagram shows that we really
invested in our NASA open Scapes Mentor
community in order to write
documentation that would let us figure
out how to use the cloud and then we
were able to then support other staff
across the NASA data centers towards a
specific workshop with researchers and
all the while contributing to the open
science Community through this
documentation in terms of design we're
really emphasizing meeting people where
they are we don't assume experience with
GitHub with quto with cloud with python
with r with quto but we do have the
expectation that everyone can learn and
teach these things and so we're able to
support folks coming from where they are
and point them to the skills that they
might need um in order to contribute or
learn um we're also able to collaborate
on this documentation across workflows
because we're using quto we're able to
share these or combine um Jupiter
notebooks our Mark IR documents as well
as contribute in our kind of home places
that we're we're most happy working
whether that's vs code Jupiter R Studio
mat lab or other
otherwise one other design element is
that we're really reusing and
complementing existing work um we found
this um documentation system framework
is a really helpful way for us to write
documentation it helped us think about
what was learning oriented and writing
those as longer form tutorials versus
what was problem oriented and could be
quick um how-to guides with copy and
paced Tech or copy and pasted code um
another part of complementing existing
work and learning from others has been
to be a part of the broader open science
and open source Community this has
really helped NASA mentors learn what's
available scope how what what the bounds
of the contribution around documentation
should be as well as co-develop and
share and get that early
feedback so what's possible from all of
this the amount of workshops that the
NASA mentors have led and supported
researchers who are now bringing their
science to the cloud and able to to
leverage the capabilities has been
really amazing and again um I'll point
you to the the place where many of these
mentors have been giving talks and
supporting the researchers which is
awesome I want to take it another level
and talk about the documentation and
process and where we're taking it from
here so putting a focus on documentation
has really enabled this NASA open Scapes
Community to grow through intentional
onboarding over the last three years so
the point that we're we're really trying
to build this sustainable Community
within NASA that's able to support user
uh researchers in the long term and have
this documentation so that folks can
contribute
so there's really been three places for
three different audiences that it's all
been designed for onboarding more NASA
staff into this Mentor community so that
they're able to support researchers the
first place was that is that we have a
project website for NASA op Scapes and
the primary audience is really for
leadership and managers to have an idea
of of all of the work that the mentors
are doing and really trying to make some
a lot of the invisible work more visible
um we share all the slides and resources
and workshops in one place so that
there's visibility there and really in
terms of an onboarding idea there um for
onboarding mentors we're really there to
invite participation and have the in
that invitation and all the information
that goes along with it not live within
a forwarded email but actually have a
place online that can be updated if
there if if
necessary the second place for
onboarding mentors is actually in that
Earth data Cloud cookbook itself we have
a contributing section that was one of
the earliest places that we developed
and that's really a welcome for new
mentors once they join this community
that's where they learn to how to access
the communication channels we have on
GitHub and slack and Jupiter Hub as well
as all of the tech um as well as how to
contribute and um think about how to do
code review and pull requests and that
kind of thing and then we have another a
third place for onboarding and that's
really in our opencape team approach
guide this is where we kind of write
documentation at this higher level for
ourselves where we're we're thinking
about our facilitation approaches the
purpose of doing the different things
our timelines our checklists and this
has been the last thing that we have had
the bandwidth to document but we're
we're um dedicated to documenting
this so it's possible from all of this
is that this Mentor Community is growing
um and and taking um more leadership of
the community because they're able to
not only repeat what we've done but
iterate and and go beyond um and they're
not having to start from scratch about
timelines or or onboarding texts for
emails and whatnot but beyond this
what's neat is that putting a focus on
documentation has Ena enabled no
officies California waterboards and
other groups to see this and repeat this
whole process um and this has been this
has all been just incredible ex and
exciting work but what's been neat is
that the NASA open Scapes mentors are
part of this bigger cross-governmental
group that are teaching each other are
learning about what works and what
doesn't work and and having a shared
place to collaborate so some of the um
advice that we have as this broader
Mentor Community is to really invest in
both Technical and social infrastructure
when you're thinking about how to
document things um documenting things
will ultimately save time there'll be
fewer emails where people are emailing
asking where things are people will feel
less stuck for uh well they'll feel
stuck for a shorter amount of times
hopefully and they'll they'll they'll
really um feel less lost and like they
like they belong and that's a really
critical thing going like just in
general but specifically during this
pandemic and hybrid work culture so re
um this does though require intention
and time and this investment in
psychological safety and growth mindset
is a really is really important for
documenting things so we have um yeah
I'll I I'll I'll leave it there um but
when you come back to um thinking about
documenting things openly for future us
it's have a place have an audience in
mind and designed for repeatability and
accessibility so thanks so
much thank you so much Julia so you
mentioned several times that there are
different levels of documentation right
there are the technical stuff there's
the high level stuff and everything in
between um the kind of recommendations
you gave for uh getting it done getting
it on the ramp is is this the same for
all these kind of different
documentation types that's a good
question um for the teaching resources
that the NASA open Scapes mentors are
putting together that
um we do that that that process is a is
a bit more intentional um well it's not
a bit more intentional it is is more
intentional so it's done in a branch um
we have drive runs we review the
materials we test things in different
places and and then that is um merged
back into the cookbook um when we're
writing documentation on that higher
level about um like the like when um
like what what sort of documentation or
what sort of um Google doc we should
have in a one-on-one call for example
that might be something that we kind of
push to main pretty quickly and it I'm
okay with that being a little Messier um
because it will still help future us on
our kind of Team level so yeah there are
different levels of like review and and
quality assurance absolutely is the
short answer fantastic so um as you said
documentation takes time and it is it is
something that gives back in a long time
span can it be difficult to kind of uh
allow management and another level to
carve out the time where you don't feel
like you have to yourself
prioritize it and uh make space for it
yeah yeah I think it I think it's kind
of a two a yes and approach um where the
idea of showing um what documentation
can do is important so if you if you
take your messages from slack and paste
it into your quto book or your Google
doc if you can show that to folks as
being useful um that can help the second
step of advocating for more time to
document but having that like early
thing to show that like minimal viable
product is is can be really helpful but
yeah I think advocating for this is part
of your time and part of your job is
like a big part of this fantastic thank
you so much Julia give her a round of
[Applause]
applause